yeah hello and welcome to this video
this is the wrong 10 report for the
London candidates I'm back in Germany
unfortunately I would have liked to
continue even for a couple of days but
my budget is limited so I needed to
return to Germany had a safe flight back
and now I'm here to present the round 10
games which have been played today and I
know you enjoy different forms of
commentary also by more than one person
so I've got a friend over here who join
me for dinner now he's interested to see
how how am i recording these videos
actually so he joined me and we do a
duel here for this round um my friend is
you can cuff it I do it in German
pronunciation he's a freedom master also
living in the same city as I am in this
book it's also book author and did I
mention it's a film master he's a good
player so we'd do a nice dual commentary
for you yeah yeah yeah hi there thanks
for introducing me and yeah I'm very
glad to be here and being part of your
show yeah thanks
so the kind to him is new to recording
videos so let's let's see yeah maybe we
you will recognize I'm a bit excited
about this yes okay what it did we'll
work on so we'll have four games as
usual and that was an interesting round
with very little drawers some of you
disliked drawers so we'll start right
now with the least interesting game got
your job of against villa and as some is
expected we got a Google cloud and in
fact my friend he is a goon for expert
he knows more about this opening than I
do yeah okay so I employed a little
effort since many years but okay so it's
a very difficult opening because you
always have to be up-to-date
yeah so many novelties that came up with
last year's and yes very difficult and
very complicated opening in general yeah
there are many many lines that Dwight
can can try against the goon father I
think my job of plays a couple of them
it's not a specific expert in one line
and he is going for the rook be one line
which has been a long-term favorite
offer especially of Boris Gelfand he
plays the plate at a lot in the 90s and
there's realize of course a wide
experience as he played the goon firm
since his childhood even when he played
the World Juniors he induce booked in
this town where I was sitting right now
in 1992 you became I think he was second
place in the world juniors and back then
even he played the golfer so he knows it
really ok since his childhood and okay
the rupee one there are many lines
against this bunch of the main line
arguably is this check and yeah white
only has two choices you can play the
very unique Queen d2 which leads to a
queen exchange but okay the main thing
of course is the Bishop d2 move after
which black grabs the a to pawn and
white castles so white is sacrificing
the spot actually what is the
compensation some points white for
example has a very nice pawn Center and
D&D pawn and it can obviously affect to
to go forward with one of them in five
or a five and okay so it's not too easy
to develop the Queen side in fact
because we have some pressure on b7 and
Bishop
on CH SP protectant yeah
so on as well that's the Queen on a -
maybe we have to watch that here is it's
not hanging around some sometimes yeah
so yeah maybe black hair has to lose
some some some some time to to get the
thing back and yeah
so I think it's both opponent of course
yeah the thing is this queen is exposed
here but it also in a way helps - yeah
hidden the white from getting the pieces
on the square so we once want them to be
so let's say this move it's not about
the Queen it's someone somehow also a
bit a bit annoying for white and the
good thing for black in this position is
he has a very simple plan just push the
April 2 a1 and win the game so this all
sounds very nice but in fact the reality
of this line is it has been played like
for 20 years or somewhat more even and
it's all very much worked out what black
tries to do is he very often gives up
one of those pawns and tries to get
quick counter play and so it okay Bishop
g4 which is arguably the main line yes
instead of disruption for black have
some alternatives as you already
mentioned a f5 at once this is a
possibility
I also also b6 is playable if you do not
want to protect fast palm on b7 Internet
let the rook and and I think are also
Queen Queen six has been played and yeah
so you can see there are lots of options
the other thing is if black goes in for
this line so if you for instance
instance in Flour employ the goon
and you need some line against rupee 1
this is the line where you really need
to learn everything you cannot play this
position based on on general principles
or some some rule that you try to follow
you need to exactly know the moves but
woodland is playing Bishop g4 which is
answered by Bishop g5 in fact they are
both pawn saying but black is trying to
do e sacrifices one pawn back to get
these pieces out and now he's even
playing H sticks encouraging Y to take
but what doesn't want to take I think
this this leads to nothing as black gets
the gone back yeah yeah absolute right
so I think that's the reason why they're
catching the e pawn is not not the best
move in this position so you know I just
Joyce Beck yeah
actually yeah i think i think the main
the main point was to to get the Bishop
to e3 where it is better than d2 but he
argues they wrote everything yeah that
this is a point of a check at some point
yeah okay go he went Knight to c6
getting getting pressure here and if
white would actually take I think
they're already technical ideas coming
for example something like this is
always the possibility maybe it is not
working in this is exposition but the
counter play is there on default white
doesn't want to waste a move really he
wants to push the pawn so it goes d5 and
all the knight is hanging and yeah it
doesn't really have a good square I mean
where do you want to go if you go to e5
there's no this is not on you but like
white can probably just take yeah this
is this is a problem for me because it
is on the 7th and at xt7 yeah so so he
goes to 85 right plays rook e1 then this
is to move the the night at some point
that it is actually possible to to move
it other
there's always this annoying pressure
honey - yeah and positional Queen on a -
and night on a five looks a bit awkward
but I think it's not so easy for right -
yeah the problem is that this Bishop is
exceptionally strong and if it weren't
for this bishop of course there's just a
muffler group a one addressing the Queen
but right now White has no move
whatsoever to attack it even so this is
the problem white is going that de for
you
blocking this diagonal so now he
actually maybe is able to to attack the
Queen black drop back and now we come to
the only to be honest only interesting
position of this game where White has
some choice he can play on basically I
can attack blacks queen all the way
through and black has a hard time to
escape this is the problem in the game
they just repeat it but what would would
be a consequence if if the black Queen
goes to two three three now we can look
at this let's let's have a brief look at
Queen to see three the Queen what does
the Queen doing on system he probably
just tries to yeah to get back is
reduces c7 maybe so get back to to to
blacks camp the question is can white
continue to take it I mean just try this
just for hard you will to save or empty
six maybe maybe no I'm never to go to
these six young brother seems playable I
mean why why shouldn't you let play this
you know you can try maybe one idea is
save Queen d2 just to okay attack this
with the table I think okay it's
something you don't like to play a move
like g5 so I think it's 55 looks very
losing your furniture maybe here and
then okay but maybe
some typical ideas like roopd 8 and
maybe to the pawn to e6 just yeah
Brittany the Lincoln Center protect the
center yeah I think like black could
have you could have continued I mean
also here there would have been Queen a3
just with this route it's a possibility
alright and and in this position white
also um it's not actually forced to play
okay one there are certainly other moves
one move could be for example Bishop a6
this also was this idea to like have
control about over see rate okay yeah so
new route can go to c8 and white can now
try to continue to increase the pressure
you could try let's say Queen to d3 and
then root K 1 and then the Queen is
actually trapped yeah yeah so there are
possibilities to continue the game and
in fact what I think is they both don't
have the greatest tournament her job of
his on last place I think or close to
last is last place right
I think he's only last place is nice
it's a terrible tournament and Sevilla
and I've had a good start but after that
him he lost two games didn't he lose two
games I think two games right he's on -1
so he doesn't have a real chance to to
do something in the tournament and
probably then just thought okay let's
wrap this up
and have a free day what I actually find
curious is they have those 30 moves rule
you cannot make a draw
before mover t the only receptionist is
a perpetual or some sort of repetition
of moves like we have here but they
happen to consult an arbiter matera
stand and this is interesting actually
because I think if I would would be the
arbiter and they would ask me to give
them a draw basically because there are
no possibilities to avoid it then I
would have declined this request because
you can avoid it but I don't know maybe
they don't want to be too too harsh on
the players but in fact if you want
want to have this rule 30 mins rule you
should be well enforcing it in this way
and not allow them to make this draw I
can understand both players in a way
because it also seems a bit risky to not
make it in a way but mostly I think it
was because my job of simply doesn't
want to play this unclear position and
after he lost all this games okay but if
you have your obviously lost this game
was black against specula I think so
yeah maybe I see I expected him to yeah
it was it was a bit late now
a bit lame too to make this draw but
yeah what what can you do
I think actually the arbiter should
shouldn't have allowed that but okay
let's not make a big fuss about that
because the three other games had had
good content to look at so let's err
should switch to a grease shock against
Kramnik so on the tournament standings
is that gree shock was in quite decent
shape but then he he lost the last round
or am I wrong no it was too dramatic but
it's not really in big contention he
would need a win then in a way maybe and
Kramnik also needs a win somehow to to
catch up so let's see what opening does
Kramnik played for win the bloody of
course yeah what else this is the same
opening the always plays even if he's
not looking for win he's a very
principled and in a way and beyond I
just shot also had this story that he
always tells when Kramnik plays the
balloon that it is crumb Nixon as he
told short at one point that is kramnik
personal goal to make people stop to
play for because of the balloon so he
wants to review tea for once percent for
all because as he said you know when you
play you for this pawn is not protected
and it's an important point
yeah well Grisha actually is a prince
play doesn't play d3 which is maybe even
more common nowadays cards and almost
always place this surprisingly as is
such a great end game player but he
doesn't play castles so okay that's kind
of short we got the main line of the
Berlin wall here this this end game
do you actually play this is what the
side game when you play 1.e4 but
actually I have to say here if I know my
opponent plays d5 on first move I player
first d4 okay this is my choice oh yeah
this is very popular among the top
players as I think it was real oh is
that one device the ultimate anti Berlin
and empty marshal idea yeah so okay well
Grisha didn't went for an anti-bullying
with one before he can play one before
but he he he obviously wanted the
endgame here against Kramnik because you
can't be relatively sure that Kramnik
would play it okay so it went 93 and at
this point black has a big choice here
on news 9 I actually played the Berlin a
couple of times black when I started out
to play one year for 25 because I wanted
some line as black that can be learned
relatively easily and back then I always
played the old North King late but in
fact black in this position has some
played almost any illegal move that
makes at least a little bit of sense
play dumb you should be 7 Bishop e6
almost a move 97 h6 you can play
basically everything in a kramnik played
Bishop d7 so do you know what's the idea
about the Smith I think Kramnik sold the
idea in this match against toss power
you have the weapon he played it against
yes the idea
recall it correctly is to play a king c8
and b6
and so travel to a place for a king and
here on b7 yeah that's exactly the point
did the old way to play this old means
like back from the 60s or 70s was to as
I mentioned as I played it
not that I planted in the 70s I'm not
that old but I actually had looked at
this King e8 move the problem is a bit
of this whole structure that black has
lost his castling rights if black would
be able to cancel actually by some kind
of miracle then it would instantly be
probably better in this position because
it's a little bit like an exchange Roy
Lopes where white has played a 45 and a
45 it's not the kind of move that you
would like to play actually if you would
imagine this position with white having
the pawn on e4 instead of me five well
not in a position where you can take the
knight but just from a structural point
of view this will also benefit white
greatly because this is before five
advanced has weakened all the light
squares so black very often has got good
play on the light squares well okay he
went Bishop d7 the ideas as mentioned to
get the King quickly to c2 to b7 and
that have the rooks connected if black
manages to connect the rooks he is
usually fine okay why it goes h3 which
is the main moves in this position and
this has many ideas
one is to prepare you for that's what
generally speaking wants to expand with
four points against three and the other
idea very often is Bishop f4 to h2 so
that you have a square away level on h2
so it's a good multipurpose move and
Kramnik plays h6 yeah it's hard to do
without this move in the long run
because of not this one
Knight g5 Knight g5 attack step 7 so
this is why he goes a chest
and now rookie one yeah this has
probably a direct idea what would write
play if black plays and nothing with
what do you think b6 I think I know it
should be six there should be a six man
because after this black guy needs to
tie up his positioner like like this and
it looks very ugly it's probably not
directly winning but it can continue
with 94 looks look it's wrong yeah there
are there are many ideas in general I
think White's pawn on e5 it's not such a
great great help and very often this is
six minutes can be a really good idea to
get to release the energy of White's
position this is also why black wants to
prevent this he went to c8 with the king
so let's just get out of this if white
now go c6 you simply take it and it's
completely pointless so I'm one general
thing about this position is to look at
the the pieces what kind of pieces do
you want to exchange and what pieces do
you want to keep on the board and in
fact what amazes me about this game and
receive this later is the handling of
this Bishop the f8 bishop is a very
important piece for black here in terms
of being a bad piece it's not really a
great piece because what quite often
you're forced to play c5 at some point
and then this Bishop is bad but black
wants to do quite often is to exchange
this bishop for night
for example if white let's just continue
played a4 a5 b 3 for example now black
plays b6
continuing the plan but just just to
make it clear black would play this move
then white only has got one in one
response he must move the knight he
cannot play this move
as this would immediately lead to a good
position for black because of the light
squares and this is very important to
note in this position black wants to get
rid of the bishop but mostly he's not
able to so let's see what happens and
keep this this bishop thing in mind
yeah why does black play 97 maybe he
likes to have done that on guzik's put
put some pressure on e5 like it's often
Alvia it's often an idea to get it to g6
I think it has got two ideas at Tech c5
it sometimes can go even to a form to e6
and it also allow us to protect this
rook on h8 this is often an interesting
point let's look at what happens which
roopd to c5 hook-and-eye - okay this is
not so important
look here this Knight is protecting the
rook
c4 well let's let's just look at rock
the a.m. it looks it looks tempting
right little government and now you see
why the nod is on g6 because next move
you actually are able to play Bishop e7
and get rid of the rook if you cannot
manage to get rid of this rook
you have a very unhappy life as black
you need to get rid of this piece this
is why it goes to g6 quite quite this is
form to note this is already just very
very deep yeah I'm not probably a wizard
with explain you simply wouldn't find it
yeah kramnik look at the time Kramnik
has spent 10 minutes here he held this
inside out and grew shocked has spent
one hour 20 I mean this is yes that's
what I am
Oscar is about him was vast wish my
cream prepared for this
yeah on its nine it's funny it seems
that he is yeah not not very well to
prepare for it but I think yeah for sure
this variation it sometimes sometimes
strange um you know I'm are you
you think you know okay they prepare for
this specific line why isn't he playing
faster awareness the brilliant idea
coming actually in this game it's
nowhere to be found
no idea I have no idea what his specific
idea was I mean one point of this
position is of course that it is rather
difficult for white to lose I mean it's
a very safe kind of setup if you play it
decently and don't let yourself into
some specific trouble then you should be
okay in this type of end game but it's
not um something that troubles black in
a way you've made all the normal-looking
moves and spend about ten minutes on
that okay but one thing that it's
important here look at the bone
structure this is very important black
here has a very simple plan to win the
game what he wants to do is he wants to
exchange all roofs and exchanged those
nights against night g8 and the bishop
on f8 if we at the end have opposite
colored bishops and they're only Bishop
g2 a b2 and is six on the board and
black plays Bishop f5 C 2 B 3 a 4 B 3 a
4 and then pacman style you eat up all
the Queen's are pawns I actually want
games with this exactly in this fashion
okay yeah and this is why you need to be
very cautious about the queenside pawns
here and this is flex basic idea in this
structure to get this bishop and at the
end window or Queen side and the fun
thing is look at the game what happens
he plays Bishop d7 93 d7 95 or looking
very very normal route d8 so remember
what I said white should never ever
exchange the night again the bishop
because the bishop is a stupid piece
it obviously is it's looking at those
pawns it doesn't have something to tech
in contrast to the e6 Bishop the e6
Bishop has always the Pegman maneuver
but the Bishop e7 has got nothing of the
sort
and the amazing thing is that drillship
took the bishop when short saw this move
in the in the in the booth he was
completely shocked that he took the
bishop because he said this is such a
gross positional error that he could not
believe that he actually played things
so I'm okay it's probably an error but
nothing that should cost the game it's
still very curious why he did this
because white can play all sorts of
nothing moves and be fine I mean what is
black exactly doing against this move
for example or some other nothing
movement probably black cat oh yeah yeah
but what about if like simply you that
is the route also on on a d5 and try out
this example and play in place that
can't rub you can try that so maybe we
should thought you know later oh I have
to have to take anyway anyway but now
I'll kill it so it's really it's
possible maybe you could have been
waiting for it and one point could be
that he's somehow confused something in
the move orders at the beginning and he
recognized okay I don't have anything
so let's trade all this off and make it
wrong in fact um this actually should
have happened but let's see what what
exactly was played the fun fun fact is
that kramnik still only had 20 minutes
spent I mean he knows as mentioned all
this inside for this he took some time
this is interesting he took 20 minutes
for g5 I guess at this point here he was
trying to play in some way to keep some
play in the position maybe trying to to
get something because black has as
mentioned a really technically
relatively clear plan exchanged the
Knights exchanged the rooks and you
winning yeah Bishop to see to okay you
need to go to and actually reach c2 but
if you manage to win yeah so maybe this
actually was the idea like activating
the night and trying to force a nice
exchange okay yeah but maybe kramnik
wasn't sure if he should place these
pawns on edge on black on black squares
because maybe uh after exchanging
everything about the bishops there's a
bit of a b2 has the same plan to catch
some support on the on the Queen side
yeah you might suppose maybe with some
ideas to with Bishop see one h4 and
something like this yeah right it's
possible placing them on dark squares
can have a similar effect of course
those pawns on the Queen side they
theoretically could could have been
attacked by the bishop as well it simply
doesn't reach them this is the problem
yeah you're right g5 is certainly am
quite a committal move you cannot go
back after once you have have it on on
g5 black of course here is trying to
play for win I mean he could easily play
rook g8 a rock d8 for example let's look
at this here and 93 it's it's probably
um it's probably not happening what the
only thing that why doesn't doesn't need
to allow us that you cannot take here
for example can I take that and now we
have to as mention unpack membership so
what needs to to retreat here and and
just stay put play g4 in the near future
yeah and black is the one trying um he
tries g5 93 rock th and all the exchange
we have quite a similar situation as
discussed before there's only g5 plate
and now this this is interesting kramnik
tries a different approach he threatens
mission c2 and this way forces the
exchange of knives
yeah against and he has to take the shop
yeah otherwise fish up c2 anyway no and
what white could theoretically think
about this but it's better up this this
looks this was very passive ends quite
quite ugly a black has probably there
maybe you can win wouldn't mean if I've
already yeah if you look at this luck
here and then came to me it's almost
dawn yeah the problem is this is one
advantage of putting the Polo GTI
Adelphia it cuts it cuts the e5 pawn
from his forces
so yeah this force the exchange you know
gue should grip 24 and now this is
interesting
two minutes 58 seconds the clock here
all I see is usually not 100% correct it
is off by a couple of seconds sometimes
but the general direction of the time is
right he might have had 320 or 240 or
something it is quite okay this clock
and kramnik had one hour 10 left of
course 25 moves or something or 22 moves
of preparation and the rest wasn't so
difficult as well yeah Kramnik goes
tonight to deform and this is so of
course putting grease up to the test
yes F that moves to make this pawn is
hanging what is why it's supposed to do
yeah
it seems that the scheme is the only way
to to get rid of this night and to Italy
yeah to enter the pong ending but ok who
can calculate his pawn ending was this
shortened of time this is really the
problem the King King and pawn endings
are always a bit tricky because they're
they're seldom like they're not like
group endings and Luke endings sometimes
you can say one side is slightly better
and they are drawing chances drawing
margins or whatever this doesn't exist
thinking of born innings they're they're
drawn or they're lost for one side yet
they're almost like a mathematical
equation with some result there's this
one zero or draw and it's not like
slightly better or something and well
the unlucky thing for Grisha is he took
this night and - he well he answered
this question wrong this is losing yeah
this leads to a lost thing in poem but
what they've done yeah there was there
was one one idea and it's it's if you if
you look at it later it seems very easy
but the thing is you need to do it in
two minutes and you need to recognize
not only that the thing that you that he
could have played was okay but the King
and pawn ending actually is not okay he
needs to do two things
yeah notice the one thing is losing and
see that the other one is actually all
right he could have played King to e3
and if like now it takes this is six we
mentioned this lot earlier that this is
probably right it's funny that's what I
and you said you said at the points on
dark squares and this is actually
happening now King two is seven probably
black can also take but let's say it
takes then there's Bishop g7 and oops no
not this one
it's oh I think this suddenly looks very
difficult for black yeah as I say we
should even give us this is lost its
lost so black like cannot play this way
you can only six play King he said this
is a bit stronger but look at this
blacks got the bishop in place yeah and
this probably needs to lead to lots of
problems for black so what does this
mean
does Chris Cook even the chance to get
an advantage I don't know
black doesn't need to take it's not a
false move black would simply draw back
to e6 and this is what he should have
done anyway good white get to this
position and play play this it's not
quite clear maybe why this is doing
quite okay maybe he had some some some
fear that Knight f4 to h3 was a problem
I don't know
and boy simply did a complete
miscalculation in the King and pawn
ending I mean this position white should
lose I think it's pretty clear that what
should you see can always also get
through bishop here yes I'm on contrary
maybe maybe black does the one who has
to be careful as possible yeah it's
possible
I mean I think one idea that that
Cromley cast was really give he suddenly
saw that the King and pawn ending is
lost pretty sure that Kramnik noticed
that and he wanted to set this trap he
was probably thinking okay if I don't go
to deform warehouse I mean you could go
here and then you need to go to go here
anyway so unless it's basically at the
same position same position so he went
to d4 and basically set this one big
trap and grew shock fare right into it
with little time and this is once again
this tournament shows us how important
time management is if we shock
didn't you wouldn't have spent so much
time if he would have just one or two
minutes more I'm pretty sure he would
figure out that the component game is
lost but well he basically loses this
because of bad time management but let's
figure out how this ended because it's
not so sad evident that this is lost
let's look at this black takes King into
King b7 I think this is all very very
clear what else should should be done
and in this position like of course has
got a protected passer but is it really
enough went to e4 King to e6 and yeah
what now this is a bit of a surprise but
yeah so much moves this only this one is
only f4 big stakes and ok now this is
the problem yeah what what must stop the
pawn he only has this move King d5 King
b3 and f4 and now this is yeah if we had
pac-man before this was based in way
that's right the black king is just
entering here in rates white scam that
takes all the pawns
I think he probably resides here right
knowing just like probably didn't have
any time so there were a couple of moves
plate and yeah now reside yeah black
simply heads over and and eats the Queen
side yeah this was really a really bad
right this must mean it is it is it's
actually relatively easy it's really a
problem of the Crimea he would never do
that with a little bit more time on the
clock okay
so at the end a matter of time
management it was not really much of a
matter of quality of moves but but a
matter of matter of time so bit of the
unlucky knows but the important point of
course for
kramnik who's still in the race if he
wouldn't have won and stayed on plus 1
then Carson on Aronian probably too far
it's also matter of it lets less and
less rounds to come it's nice if you say
ok it's just one point yeah but there
are also very few rounds left now so he
needs to win at some point and he was
lucky he was very unlucky in this
tournament at TM luck was on his side so
next game is Aronian against even
shocked and even sugars probably the
most unpredictable dick table player not
only in this tournament but probably in
the holder who lovingly chess and what
is this actually the Buddhist very
surprised the Budapest ambit he comes up
with the Budapest I'm not even sure if
the one shook has played this before but
he played all kinds of stuff one thing
can you can be sure that aronia didn't
prepare this I'm not sure if he prepared
anyway and huge detail because you once
you really can't play everything so I
think even shook already spent two
minutes on his first move yeah he does
so does he spend all kinds of time in
situations that are really hard to
really hard to understand so um yeah ok
this is one of the main lines right has
protected the pole here on e5 and black
can give this check on before yeah here
White has a principled choice of course
he can play em Knight c3 or 92 and the
more popular move nowadays actually is
night to d2 after which um normally
black continues with roof like 27 he
three Knight takes Knight takes Knight
takes Bishop e2 something like this
leading to
yeah this actually is the point of this
Budapest a gambit sooner or later he
will get the pawn back only five you
know and I think all those nights when
white tries to to to hold his pawn are
maybe not not the best nights for whites
so yeah very often white doesn't really
care about the pawn and just place in
this fashion and Sonya there's actually
one line where you can't keep the pawn
and this is what Aronian played he
played 93 takes and now queen defy the
setting oh yeah this is the only line
well you can legitimately hold on to the
pawn because um black has no choice here
really there's this threat wouldn't
black must play f6 no yeah you need to
immediately force the hand here
otherwise what would kick the the bishop
the knight back to some very bad square
so this means here white really is a
pawn up but it's got a very bad pawn
structure I think this is until today
not completely shown how to evaluate
this position I think there was some
debate even even not too long ago see
Russian Viktor moskalenko I don't know
well somewhere from the former Soviet
Union he made a book yeah the the
fabulous Budapest gambit or something
where he analyzed this line in some
detail and thought black was okay and if
we look at the game actually I think we
despite the Budapest having slightly
dodgy reputation if one shop didn't have
the best position we look at this which
looks very normal I'm not sure I don't I
don't think you don't know the theory
either no no it's a it looks but it
looks very young
like I mean he's got no weakness all
points are okay and it's got a good
structure but why closer I really like
your blacks position it's probably not
so bad you are really there there you
gotta always get two positions like this
was service to Budapest I may be is
blows plates but yeah okay yeah it's not
possible this I wish Black has at least
some some ideas and some points to to
attack yeah c4 c3 there are weaknesses
but of course the position has one
serious long-term drawback and this
means why it's got two bishops this is
of course one problem I think that's
also one issue with the Budapest in
general that this Bishop before always
gives up this bishop against the knight
on D - on c3 you will never keep it and
the bishop airs of course the big deal
in modern chess it always works but in
modern chess especially so let's see
what continued here ok one ok needed to
protect this and the one shook when
teenage aid which is quite a good
multi-purpose move you want to get the
King out of possible checks yeah on d5
on c4 it can always be in some sort of
check it some gap also a common theme in
lots of openings where the F pawn is
moved to move the King on the side and
now wide when tonight reform an ID for
sorry that default and this is to to use
the bishop now black probably needs to
play as he did in the game play Knight
to e5 and this force is why to take on
five so he managed to get rid of one of
the bushes and
yeah yeah Knight to f5 I'm not sure was
it did you [ __ ]
no no what do you think about night c2
is this maybe an idea I'm gonna give it
away like something but black has got c6
yeah probably you will play it instantly
yeah line like this and line like this
for example isn't so clear for what I
mean it looks nice you've got these
extra pawn but this Bishop is biting on
a pawn and black has got this excellent
c5 square I can get a knight day I can
get a queer there yeah I think it's a
very difficult task for for white to
make progress there are significant
issues yeah I wasn't I wouldn't be so
confident II as well how to how to make
any progress that so the question is
well but we're ready to play on Queen
side Santa Monica side is not well he
went here and this sir led to this
exchange 97th was the temple where the
Queen went back and no again there's a
really important point and it's not on
the left side of the video look at the
right side look at the times
Aronian who is the one actually being
confronted with an opening he never ever
could expect spend 33 minutes so he was
really practical about his moves and he
won sugar spent one hour 24 minutes and
how is this even possible I mean he's
the one getting in the surprise and then
in he is spending like ages forest
movers look here 15 minutes 8 minutes
Oh what more than half an hour for he
spent half an hour for this move yeah
23 and 80 83 minutes Oh anything
thirty is 38 minutes 83 the bit much 38
minutes there more than half an hour I
mean I understand that you need to look
a bit deeper and that it's all a very
difficult game but at one point you just
need to move yeah actually it appears to
play what else is there but what's he
thinking about
yeah maybe Bishop d7 but this is a great
move I cannot believe it I'm not sure
I'm really not sure it looks very very
very obvious yeah but the thing is even
even if you have a slightly better move
you you you should play a normal good
one in in like 10 minutes let's say and
not spend so much time so to cut the
story short here we got a position where
blacks certainly is quite okay we see
the whole kind of structure is nice it's
got a good square here this Bishop is
limited and even if you look at the
position black has got one very good
idea we put it on the board server you
know Mowgli here black has excellent
play against the spawn and probably will
win the form so even Chuck has played
played really well I think and got a
very interesting playable position but
he's down to 20 minutes and this means
him now must make 19 moves in 19 minutes
which still is doable but you need to
well be a bit quicker now and I don't
know I mean the next move you will see
also a strength of Iranian you know he
plays very very tricky and in times
progress of his opponent yeah yeah it's
a very tricky player so this is the only
chance
maybe yeah pickup before to follow yeah
maybe to be to beat the kingside
exploiting the divine maybe it's yeah
yeah the position is yes Chancellor of
the white the position is some problem
maybe it is he who maybe it is unclear
but one thing is clear Aronian has much
more time to to to play and evaluate the
position correctly a bunch of must play
was made relatively quickly and you must
start to now spend less time this is
three minutes this is a must be very
careful what would happen we figured it
takes the pawn on see if he takes it win
quiz before you know
yeah well probably it's an exchange I do
listen okay that's another point and but
it's not it's not so clear if this is if
this is so great I mean let's say I play
I okay but playing past I suppose
letting when they're reactive will be
one in v1 would be one yet yeah this is
good for more like take maybe a 4 and a
4 yeah yeah alright yeah this is good
therefore a 5 and this also undermines
the point this is a very typical way to
get your Bishop active this Bishop looks
like it's writing on granite but if you
manage to shove this pawn all the way to
a 6 then this Bishop will get good again
for example let's say black plays here a
five-night moves when you can even take
it can you take oh yeah 9005 yeah you
can get back and it's one idea it's one
idea one ideas to just go here and all
maybe this is you this is wrong a
stronger you keep on and you keep it up
so this a porn movie serves a very
interesting thing to remember so you
very often this way you can activate
your bishop if you get the point all the
way up to ace
okay but this is some line that probably
in one choke I think relatively quickly
dismissed be clear you don't want you
don't want to want to have the piece on
the seventh but they played this first
and now King g7 uh-huh yeah well okay
there was Bishop d6 threatens yeah maybe
now it takes like when we could have
taken now okay
this also also prevents Bishop g6 yeah
this is very uh no yes but black like
should like be in trouble I mean just on
general grounds this Bishop and the
Queen are attacking but this is not so
dangerous I think at the moment the
bishop has a good position but there's
no no direct threats and black should be
able to defend this I mean King here
look at seven protecting the sir yeah so
but where are the threats
why doesn't have white that's because I
don't see anything he could do wanna be
okay he can double ropes but what's the
if left you can go here first okay yeah
I know there there are many many ways to
go black blood even could could go let
just just say here I mean it's uncanny
inside it's a bit annoying
okay King's yourself maybe even just
here
I know intending this I want to get out
of this idea of course it's a bit a bit
annoying in the long run yeah I don't
think that blacks should be in bad shape
I mean but I think in the game it wasn't
a big big problem as Valley went King g7
King G - yeah Kim G - probably - to
allow the F pawn at some point get out
of out of this now he took
we have this very very similar position
and rook t1 yeah this is almost what we
got him just just not King G - what we
got in the line before yeah huronian
coordinate up on the clock actually but
there's another four hangings and you
can take on me too actually
yeah he did he took it you know why not
yeah and now the question is what is
happening like it's one point up by now
and we're companies I know why just to
show something now he has to create some
maybe hmm I don't know what would be an
idea king queen g5 h4 h5 something like
this I don't know yeah one one thing
that you see you see is that bishops
sometimes very clumsy at taking pieces
yeah it's this bishop seems nice only
four but it just bites on those pawns
it's not like a night where you
sometimes can somehow get near the king
and then play four tricks huh just
somehow maybe have to try - no - big
machine six yeah okay take a little bit
to snow because we have some tried
something else
okay this try to use the pieces you know
just pad pieces okay look it's really
tiny maybe five okay this but it's a bit
of worm I don't know crossing the point
of no return with him I think it should
have some sound robux as well we we can
wind f4 maybe later you can get this
Knight to f4 yeah yeah it's a risky move
it's certainly risky I think this is
really a very very decisive point of the
tournament here for Aronian if he would
lose this game then he's out of it he
lost against Gelfand
wrong before and if he
lose this one more game than his out
basically that this is too much
being on plus one is just not enough so
he needs to at least not lose this I
mean if for some reason that would end
in a draw I think this is still okay but
you cannot lose but at the moment he
needs to try to stir up some trouble
otherwise it's just material don't look
at form you know this looks like a
normally no you look at the time six
down to six minutes and 50 seconds he
took home five twenty five minutes for
this this is this one yeah this is over
this side with him but this is not this
is at least a complicated position he
sometimes takes this time in lame
positions okay Bishop f5 this is of
course a cool move that is let's first
figure out what happens if like there's
fees
yeah that's not look f7 is not on
anymore this is probably the racism oh
this is oh this is amazing mate okay you
have here we have two this is also made
you have to sacrifice again you go back
here yeah
and what is this at the end
okay first body Canton what has got an
extra pawn right yeah an extra pawn and
blacks going very weak in very Kingdom
yeah the rule coordinated you have free
pass on the efferent h-file yeah yeah
what should be better for dinner oh it's
not food it's always it's always a bit
tricky with with two rooks them against
the Queen because if you somehow get
into coordination you get get into
trouble but here you get also this extra
pawn and it's not so easy to even
suggest a direct moving black probably
goes something like this
and after that let's say just just just
for argument's sake you played this with
this idea how does look on a phone get
up there game yeah it's a bit a bit
problematic and if you let's say you
move it away
then there's the F pawn yeah it's
probably probably over you cannot you
cannot take the bishop so this is a nice
shot yeah by Aronian okay you don't have
to take this now over when the bishop
isn't only for anymore yeah you can
complain now you mind if I maybe
consider 95 yeah what some awesome let's
say hmm what is what is actually
threatened
yeah well it's roopd 7s of the luckiest
before it's in failure
you cannot do some leaps like this you
only move 395 I was just thinking let's
say I return here yeah that does also
locations
and place is not simply actually this
stuff
ah rook air-five okay that's a big
difference isn't everything yeah yeah
yeah this is good for this is good for
Mac so 95 this is also what you played
but now it's down to two minutes forty
four so how many well it's it's doable
in the Blitz game but if the opponent
has got lots of time and pauses your
problems here you've got one problem a
very direct one and yeah you need to
solve it now how do you parry Queen
takes h7 okay so in the Blitz game I
would play rook at a trade yeah yeah
also in a board game probably am the one
should only had two minutes he played
this yeah and well in fact it tests it
has a problem it has got a big drawback
and this is the move III attacking the
rook and why does okay so why is this
problem go to see 400 c4 can check is it
so such a problem now white can shake no
if you take on g6 that's actually this
move
oh look q3
I can stop the ball I can still go here
yeah
can't say this so the pawn is pinned
yeah one important thing is that here
the queen is always covering a
three-year otherwise 93 would be in the
show black cannot really take because
this is it's also with check er very
important yeah so yeah now white
threatens very very big checks with this
with this Bishop yeah it's terrible and
all the blacks
is everything yeah yeah yeah you're
right this is this is actually a very
important thing to notice again and
again very often attacks on the king
with Queens on the board are very often
successful in situations where the TECA
has got the Queen in play like here it
is doing things and the defender has got
the Queen somewhere off-site like here
yeah and this really means that in the
area of the board where it counts White
has something of an extra Queen so might
be that we would come back to the theme
on our last game yeah the queen is
offside and this is the problem so what
is this so rook h8 was played and Jeff
can you do them yeah the thing is if you
if you check your with with the computer
it actually says h5 would draw okay but
it's it's not easy at all of course the
thing that would irritate me here is
Quincy five here attacking g6 but yeah
the thing is the computers of course
without mercy it just takes here and
says that this is fine interesting okay
this is this is very very difficult this
is surprising if you are it what what
would happen let's say okay idea yeah
then rookie is simply rupees six and the
comparison is protected or going how
will this actually wins okay this looks
very dangerous hmm how the second how
does you let protect can give a check on
there for now you can also just check
here King somewhere and Queen backyard
something
this yeah wow this is super complicated
yeah well you can work it out in a
correspondence game or in a game way
home hey VF Jason is very strong so
maybe I wonder company H for you can go
to to h5 booster night
yeah it is possible this is Roy says to
mr. Washington D you can get rid of can
easily move repetition yeah and you can
easily construct a drawing here with a
repetition of moves
yeah so to just get back to what
happened Aronian played this and now if
one should have played aged 500 this is
really really I'm sure he's he saw okay
25 and he didn't see the difference
between g5 like before they are probably
we went here and after 83 this rook was
was the nerve in a bad spot iam yeah he
probably thought he was losing anyway if
you if you dismiss age 5 you must play
rook h8 and then probably he saw that
he's in big trouble after this but well
with two minutes you know he was just
simply have half this problem we cannot
calculate anymore so he took him took
the bishop as we showed if he would drop
back with the rook there's this is this
coming yeah should be you know should be
winning yeah this is see this white
Chuck and falls on Knight takes
I'm saying you should be could go to the
corner yeah each one
yeah in fact the game here was ended oh
okay yeah ah
he played magic boy and there's a while
what step 0 to the rope
yeah this means yeah five zeros in a row
that also could stand for cookies five
losses
and I think four of them three at least
we're on time I think maybe even four in
those games against our own young he
lost one time this the first game I
think yeah yeah I think you're right
I'm thinking what what what was this
game
I mean Ian had black what was this was
it very complicated
being gay away attacked with H points or
you know sometimes you're right you know
sometimes it's covered the game is epic
King edge won yet probably this what
would happen King edge one takes him and
then at the end there's this coming
again and your king is the problem with
lose already with one with made in one
and yeah
rook on these tablets is deadly
unfortunately yeah yeah well you cannot
play successfully at this level if you
don't manage your time look at the end
of the game Aronian still has 23 minutes
left he could have easily spent time
before at some point but he sort of
always had he left himself with a couple
of minutes extra time reserved if it
should get really really really
complicated at some point that he has
some time to calculate it probably and
if one job simply didn't have any time
at the end and overstepped the time
limit even but it was it was lost at
least two it's not a huge consolation
but it feels even worse a few misstep a
little time but anyway I'm very happy
that he used openings it seems that it's
playable also on top level yeah yeah
it's very often that people dismiss
openings on some sort of general opinion
that it's maybe not 100 percent okay but
it certainly am a play will opening I
don't think that in this kind of
position white should get more than a
slight advantage I mean this is
if you play some sort of that's a
Queen's Gambit where you have long-term
problems with you see eight bishop and
oops and trying to defend the position
you were probably also not not much
better off than here we've got all kinds
of active pieces and active play so it's
a good thing to have this variety in the
tournament they're not the same openings
all over again let's say I'm compared to
this candidates matches form and with
that we had 2011 in Kazan in Russia
where they all the time plate the Queens
gambit declined that you were liable to
fell asleep like after ten minutes okay
so we've got three games covered and
last one is countin against gelfand and
the accountant had won the first round
game so to say against the Galvin would
like and he's certainly intended to
press a bit at least so what do we have
this is Lillian with 96 Jeff and sticks
to his guns yet prepared to stretch
Nikko for the world championship match
against Arnold and just put it on the
board this line does this is what he had
prepared for the Moscow match and he had
it on the board once and gelfand was so
excellently prepared that are not after
that gave up the open Sicilian all
together and played them we should be
five and this is what cars in here also
plays but I think he prefers this anyway
right he plays the open but yeah but
Floyd it this tournament against Roger
wolf yeah okay it wasn't so successful
yeah but the difference is against your
job of it took here instantly am yet
good job of was this this this game and
we played on the the pawn structure and
didn't really work out with Java had a
great position and that was winning even
a very important game for the tournament
if he would have won it all would have
gone differently I guess for both
players I mean even the job of after
after he missed this chance with job
offer was completely out of it okay so
he didn't take he just canceled which is
a good alternative of course 92 is seven
so you can actually capture on c6 with
the night rookie 186 and Bishop f1 so
very smooth we are setting up your piece
is very interesting this this concept
playing the Bishop to b5 and he was to
return to f1 and but the bishop function
that's what we see later he can put a
protector I'll push forward some parts
on the Queen Queen side yeah and it also
covers the King because there's no yeah
it's not possible to you to have a maid
on the background black ring yes you see
it's it's not mostly quite quite often
it it it's funny that bishops are very
often very good on the initial squares
the only thing is you actually need to
get the King out of the way so if you
two manage to castle move the rook and
put the bishop back this is very often a
good thing to do it's a very common in
the reuleaux past for example more black
plays Bishop e7 group he ate Bishop f8
back and then it's all set up nicely and
of course in the right position it can
always go back to an active post but for
the moment that doesn't hinder anything
okay so here Goffin went d5 and we see
from the time spent that this was all
very much anticipated Carlton now took
on d5 which is the normal move in fact
early agree show in this time and had
played d3 and aft 84 d5 Knight d5 it was
a quite a good position for black goo
shock actually was in big trouble that's
right and the gap one should have won
this game
he really outplayed grew shocked nicely
but somehow stumbled in time
of course Cardon does not play this
played on he played exd5 capturing and
now we have an interesting point here
for some reason girlfriend invested time
like 18 minutes and then took on d5 with
the night which really left me a bit a
bit desert because I think what I saw in
this position you can take was the Queen
25 to prevent euphoria yeah yeah I think
I thought this as well the idea could be
that right now white if white would go
d4 that's just show it black can take
and it's actually a real extra point
yeah white cannot go deform
this is a difference to the game and
probably white should do something else
I know yes pick up this now after after
Queen d5 the bishop moves again Bishop
d3 was the idea Bishop a floor this is
interesting I what I saw in some games
yeah yeah yeah yeah - too divisive three
and in twenty four before yeah this is
very nicely so long on e4 but it's also
interesting for black I agree this leads
to somewhat more let's say unbalanced
position now like in the game it's
pretty much relatively clear after a
couple of moves that only Wyatt can be
slightly better but after this
it's a whoops after Queen takes it's not
so clear what is happening it's a bill a
little bit more of a fight maybe I also
wonder what about 9c3 is this bed bed
really maybe you can return I was I beg
you and I'd like you to be here yeah you
know white white has little chance of
getting active play if you are not able
to play d4 here right if you play like
d3 and this kind of setup it's it's it's
very toothless but black is very slow
with development but well yeah that's
lower tech black
trouble over a very important career and
this is d4 yeah yeah yeah well well
maybe maybe he was considering this but
the thing is you should actually check
this out before I had that home right
okay maybe maybe he was also trying to
well anticipate what maybe Carlton has
in store after Knight takes d5 because
this is the normal movement it was
played of course also you must must add
that if you say ok you should have
anticipated and so on
Tod's will place any movie plays Knight
f3 on first move d4 c4 whatever and
Gavin cannot 100% sure to get this
position so it's understandable that he
may be Reese rechecks his preparation
okay now d4 now it is possible and
Knight f6 yeah this looks a bit strange
at first we treating the night but I
guess what what black is trying to do is
to immediately put some pressure on d4
and for some a concessional since yes
another point could be that black is
awaiting c2 c4 and yeah yeah he was who
wants to make sure that it is not coming
with a chemical black for example okay
this is a bad move but let's let's a
would play Bishop d7 then C form md5
this is really ugly
this is this gets ugly you have rook
already only one white was very quick
with getting his rook in the center and
it's supposed to black but I think
perfectly playable is to Bishop e7 like
here yeah I think this is being played
already in several games we shall be
serving in this position there like like
this again yeah probably sitting at all
d5 is not possible
you know maybe here oops not this this
could easily need to hear Jesus
yeah yeah okay let's say Knight f6
Bishop e3 play d4 was detect it took
here and play Bishop d7 so that you can
recapture here now like this and this is
a nicely paced Bishop okay but right
doesn't want to capture instantly he
plays C floor first yeah in this
position now
Galvan play some very straightforward he
just take on d4 which immediately
prepares the bishop moves on it went
like this and power developed with 93 he
could have maybe M delayed this caption
on deform and first play we should be
seven but it's not clear that this is
actually better I think
this shouldn't be a big problem this
position for black but he needs to play
accurately you know because but we will
see in this games of Bishop 24 is a very
strong piece it's almost impossible for
black to get rid of this of this Bishop
because it also covers a5 he it can go
to e5 no in fact is absolutely under
control but the group of each one as
well and yeah white white white seems to
be a bit more comfortable it's easier
for y2 to shuffle its pieces to good
squares and sort of build up something
as black it's a bit more passive here
after a three white is intending to play
before and this is a difficult choice
geffen actually opted to go for a5
stopping before it's not clear he could
have also played that just castles and
after before continue with some
relatively modest movements
Queen c7 that doesn't really help
something like this I don't want to do
that maybe this keeps the bishop one of
the Alamo maybe it we can do this but it
looks like white is slightly better I
mean simply the three against two and
this play with the space advantage it
should be a little bit a little bit of
something it's not it's not the dramatic
thing where you can actually lose
quickly as much but it looks a bit
better for white but okay you decided to
play a five I don't think this is really
a mistake do you think I mean I wouldn't
call it mistake of cross this but I
would say I would think twice about this
yeah having a 5 in is silly and in
general because you shouldn't forget you
you will yeah it will be some important
squares that'd be fine yeah he would I
think it didn't want to have before
coming really yeah
and maybe he also thought this is a
possibility high five
and let's put White's move on the body
maybe he actually had intended it's a
possibility to play a four at some point
which really really creative let's say
after a form if for some reason white
wouldn't be allowed to play exactly that
the coming moves that this would be
great for black if Roy in fact it's a
mistake here because of roof t1
intending Queen g3 and this pressure is
simply too much we can put it on the
board at say castles Queen g3 intending
this and now the Queen needs to move
gets a here then there's a really
standard the Soviet tactic 95 versus
this is very nice but what's black is
supposed to do now it threatens on f6 on
e7 and if you grab here
rookie 7 and while this is deadly
yeah this is the easy line yeah it's a
bit bad more difficult ancestors a big
problem for black he hasn't got a good
place for most powerful Queen
yeah yeah yeah black industry he needs
to take em cannot can try this like a
snow move this is the problem 25 Bishop
f6 DD 5 rupees sheriff yeah yeah move
the rook rook e8 okay yes and then you
can go something like here and take on
e6 yeah that's a disaster it's really a
disaster yeah black cannot go waveform
well he played he played correctly you
cancelled rook t1 white is simply better
mobilized he's got better pieces and
it's got Queen g3 coming and this is
actually a sequence of only moves black
now goes Queen here this is actually
necessary because Queen g3 was the
threat and black controls the square so
now Queen g3 black is glad to exchange
and relieve himself of some pressure of
course Carson doesn't do that he attacks
the Queen first it moved to be 6:23 so
this is the ideal setup black of course
now we can take here because of 95 this
is even simpler than before attacking
all kinds of stick things at the same
time the group d8
exchanged yeah of course you cannot go
here because of this one so Queen d8
group t1 and this is all very logical I
think up to this point this is very
close to 2 to optimal play where both
sides really really you can
about a five to smooth but other than
that it is very logical but now that's
Queen b6 and if you look at what happens
in the game it really seems that Queen
b6 is really a big mistake
maybe something interesting has been to
this move four minutes and four minutes
okay it's not so much maybe he miss how
you miss evaluated something in the
common complication it is it's
complicated it's not clear-cut it's a
bit of rule like this this um this
figure of speech that I learned recently
hindsight is always 20/20 which
translates to Germany - Germany
afterwards you're always more clever
than you are in the situation when you
actually sit at the board you know
afterwards while I lost after that one
maybe it should have done something
differently
so okay now I spotted cows will win the
game but the thing is thinking you have
to seriously consider Oh Queen afraid
yeah yeah this is the point this would
have been better simply because the
Queen on b6 gets a tech job we will see
in the game that this Queen will really
be a cause of concern
you always get attacked and get tactics
on the Queen if it it is on on the B
file here and on f8 it's not very active
but it also cannot be attacked this is
very nice it prepares route to d8 and
it's not so apparent what white is going
to do now he can play for example let's
say we should peer activating this piece
setting it on a good diagonal but it's
not so clear-cut
how to continue if for example black
goes here then white doesn't have a
direct way to continue maybe you even
managed to get off one pair of rooks and
after.look exchange I think the worst is
really only the rooks they don't do much
asthma but if you reduce the the amount
of pieces then the activity is not so
dangerous anymore it really seems that
this would have would have helped
girlfriends course
after this we can see that the Queen
gets attacked and it doesn't have
anything else then you go to b3 black
goes for a six maybe then you have
before coming this is quite quite an
annoyance
I cannot take him because this loses the
peace and probably very quickly the King
so it's it's not possible you need to go
here and this is really a problematic
piece now this Queen rook t3 with the
instant threat of 95 and black only has
this this is all only moves and I think
a probably galvans rational was okay
don't want to play this passive move I
want to use the Queen iya as some kind
of annoyance vector annoy white on the
on the back rank and attack things but
the problem is it doesn't work out from
a technical point of view because now
White has this very strong move be form
and black cannot take it we can do this
and now of course black cannot take it
because again of Bishop f6 and this
means that white establish this pawn do
after one then you can argue a if I fail
yeah right now be like a officers to
watch for b5 and yeah you haven't got a
good square for this Bishop on c6 you
can put a to e8 and it will remain very
very impressive yeah you really don't
want to get it to a gem it's so it's
really it's really a problematic
position now I think it's very hard to
to say if it is possible I mean I had
looked a bit at this also with the help
of the computer we didn't we didn't
really find anything good anymore
what Galvan tried is one of the tougher
defenses but it doesn't really help
he went for this
of exchange operation this only fails so
very little detail rook takes Queen
takes and now white needs to find the
all-important move and it's a very very
nice one that Queen a5 yeah putting the
Queen on free but attacking the rook
they cannot take it
yeah because although this me back
running mate and what does this mean
okay black must move the rook and he
doesn't have a good square it is
vulnerable on all kinds of squares the
only square which is not losing
immediately provenance this this one and
now just Queen to b6 and this actually M
threatens something very very hard
threat is some before to be fine
like place and nothing moves than b5 you
need to return all the way and then this
Bishop is simply simply gone yeah you
grew clear again and there's no move
they are black and can survive this yeah
you cannot move any of this and white
would simply push the seatbelt yeah
that's what I'm very happy even if I
have a bishop on it everyone exactly yes
is it the best piece you can this is to
protect the king well you can you can
view this this King side has some sort
of shield of unit yeah it's not
happening much the single Queen cannot
do anything against this so so very safe
this is worth read yeah b5 so black must
do something concrete he attacked the
rook but this also weakened of course
the spawn and in fact we see that this
pawn will get lost in in short order
like didn't really have a defense to
that
yeah and now it is gone like what lucky
to know why not blue yes actually that
yeah uh after after route de 5 after
checking the power of your 5 here yes
it's not possible to play this it's may
be possible I wonder about group 8 well
I was thinking to go here and now push
the pawn but maybe it is not yeah you
connect you can really play this him
yeah yeah yeah it was not too clear so
this is not so carry a problem any right
of you shouldn't you shouldn't exchange
each possible that that route d8 is so
it's not good I can I can maybe I can
push instantly maybe well yeah you need
to do this simply before black plays b6
need to take a chance
yes he is less regularly black doesn't
have a good move you cannot mix the e
pawn yeah cannot move the rook so it's
it's all a bit tight down yeah yeah ok
I never try it's a try maybe I think
what you wanted to do is you wanted to
quickly go through the to the first rank
to get this counter play here with the
possible Bishop movement so it took it
yeah here it looks like white should win
somehow with good technical play but
it's a it's still not so easy
ok 8 yeah this is all pretty much
normal-looking white is attacking now
the b7 pawn yes Queen
since we're less positions yeah it's a
very nice position for the Queen and
yeah the thing is what this black gum
supposed to do now actually the computer
recommends the passive defense my group
here even stranger look in seven which
looks really weird I mean I really doubt
that any human would play this but okay
this is some not really impractical move
to analyze now because Gavin played okay
one and this is a much more human
decision because what he wanted to do is
he wanted to exchange the rooks and now
get some counter play here on the first
rank with this Bishop c4 idea the only
thing is it's not working
sometimes it's so easy but I think he
would have lost anyway yeah even without
the continuation so cars will push the C
pawn queen c3 Queen d7 and now so yeah
kind of space ball why didn't he take
the pawn on c5 actually are you right
they couldn't take it could take I think
he was maybe better just to fix and the
others this one coming up with the
chemical ways away and what what is
black doing him can go here just just
for argument's sake let's see here okay
before before queen bee baby I am maybe
this is a setup where you can put some
some resistance there you're covering
you cover already setting and covering
b7 yeah but somehow it should be should
be a way to convert this but it's not
see it's not it's not completely easier
how to what you would like to you would
like to get rid of the bishop Ian and
some and some manner so yes so you think
I was thinking if you if you maybe maybe
can go here or g3 Bishop g2 maybe
there's also some tactic I mean this is
possible this is maybe a technical move
but it looks really weird
oh maybe this is this is a tactic that's
working but I'm not I'm not so sure what
it is actually doing black now that we
check you want I will take on f2 this
was my problem there because now h4 is
hanging and it's difficult to see yeah
maybe maybe this one I don't know
but okay he cannot take right it should
be something I'll take anything you will
lose yeah I'm not I'm not sure let's
just cook just cooking this is waiting
for what it is technically winning here
because it's official yeah well yeah so
maybe there's some tactical way I guess
with this extra pawn it should be
winning somehow yeah should be but he
tried for this counter play with Bishop
c4 and that first not it's not so easy
at first glance yeah you might be in
trouble with the body but okay Kyle
found some way to yeah actually just
draw another one yeah and ignored all
this yeah the pots are too advanced eggs
another hour nice tapas is not strong
okay yeah it took you in a queen for it
yeah yeah I got this Queen flow for
Bishop is very often a good trade so
Queen be one and now you need to only
have some small steps
left but the cons are just just can
advise official can't do anything
yeah until we've got b8 covered and what
we'll get a new queen it's unavoidable
yes where you can see how powerful
connected passports can be yeah no and
actually right from the opening it
always was an idea and yeah with before
that white oops
yeah I never loved this that white has
the chance to at the end get a passport
with his three against two
and here this game it actually
materialized that these pawns are at the
end the designs effector so a rather
typical game for for cars he had cut
some some slight advantage and then by
very good concrete calculation he said
so many problems for the opponent that
it actually leads to a crackdown when
the time gets gets a little bit shorter
very important to win of course for the
tournament Aronian one as well maybe a
bit a bit of a lucky win slightly lucky
against he won shock I think he was in
trouble at some point and Kramnik won
with this neat strap that group fell
into so at the end all three players
that still fight for the first place one
today the status quo hasn't changed and
this means the tournament is still on
yes so very very tense and and open cars
and sudden he's got the best chances but
it's not clear cut by any means storm
some some possibilities left yeah all
right I think we are through it's been a
long video but it also was a quite a lot
of content to cover the interesting game
since was only this one relatively yeah
an interesting draw but the other games
have been reified yeah also thanks to my
co-host here you have to thank it was
fun for me yeah I hope you enjoyed the
video make
if some kind comments and I'll be back
tomorrow with round 11 and I'll continue
of course to to cover the tournament
until the very end
it says two four hours to go thanks and
bye